le spectre d'une quatrième vague et la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants au
coeur des discussions entre eux olivier
ferrand et les représentants des corps
médical cet après midi le gouvernement
se donne le corps médical se donne
jusqu'au conseil de défense de lundi
prochain pour présenter ou non de
nouvelles mesures restrictives
on retrouve sur place notre reporter
monaco dès lors qu'ils se trouvent donc
avenue de ségur à paris bonsoir mona
depuis plusieurs jours le débat sur une
possible activation obligatoire fait
rage
il fait rage et un consensus a été
trouvé entre les différents ordres
médicaux et le ministre de la santé
olive et veyran puisque une charte a été
signée pour rendre le vaccin obligatoire
à tous les soignants cela reste
symbolique mais en tout cas un consensus
a été trouvé ici même au ministère de la
santé olivier veyrat a été fermé a
indiqué que la vaccination était une
chance elle est professionnelle à qui
nous avons parlé estiment qu'ils doivent
montrer l'exemple
sous peine de sanctions écouter les un
large consensus s'est dégagé autour
d'une obligation vaccinale
bien sûr il faudra un délai pour aller
jusqu'à la loi nous espérons que cette
déclaration commune encouragera les
soignants et les personnels de des ehpad
des secteurs sanitaires des secteurs de
l'aide à domicile à aller vers la
vaccination sur un vaccin obligatoire
quand il n'est pas respecté
l'employeur peut recourir au
licenciement ce qui me cause réelle et
sérieuse donc nous avons été jusqu'à
cette perspective
évidemment nous n'avons pas du tout
envie d'aller jusque là mais si la
vaccination obligatoire et mise en
oeuvre bien sûr il faudra en assumer
toutes les conséquences et aujourd'hui
c'est le début d'un conte a robot
je pense que tous les ordres signé
aujourd'hui avec les employeurs les
fédérations pour dire aux professionnels
de santé quels qu'ils soient aux
accompagnants aussi aux tous les
intervenants qui vont se présenter dans
des spas dans des établissements quel
que soit son niveau mais dure et qui va
être en contact avec un patient avec un
usager des souhaits avec le résident
qu'il faut absolument se vacciner voilà
c'est un message fort envoyé à tous les
soignants même si cette charte n'est que
symbolique pour l'instant elle est
professionnelle à qui nous avons parlé
espère que cette obligation sera rendu à
toute la population à cl taux de
vaccination ne commente pas partie et
les soignants et bien il pourrait y
avoir une loi qui obligerait les plus
réticents à se faire vacciner puisque il
faut savoir que le taux de vaccination
des soignants et de 57% dans les ehpad
et 64% dans les hôpitaux ce n'est pas
assez selon olivier ferrand
ministre de la santé et mona dans ce
débat quelle est la position de
l'opposition
et bien dès demain le premier ministre
jean castex reçoit lé chef de file du
parlement et des élus locaux
justement pour aborder ces questions et
tenter de trouver un consensus sur la
vaccination obligatoire pour le moment
vous l'avez compris le gouvernement
cherche des mécanismes d'incitation de
la vaccination à des français alors que
le variant delta et gagne du terrain
vraisemblablement en france le
gouvernement se donne jusqu'au conseil
de défense sanitaire prévue le lundi 12
juillet pour présenter ou non de
nouvelles restrictions et concernant la
vaccination obligatoire pour certaines
professions ou encore l'extension du
pass sanitaire des annonces sont donc
attendus lors de la prochaine allocution
du président de la république la semaine
prochaine merci mon âme ou dès lors
devant le ministère de la santé à paris